sources tell CBS News that white house
advisors are encouraging the President
to stand firm on his demands to end the
shutdown but mr. Trump is showing more
flexibility in negotiations than we've
seen before chief Washington
correspondent major Garrett is with us
major good morning Gordon where's the
slow give that we're saying well the
slow give is about if Mitch McConnell
the Senate Republican leader and the
majority leader is Charles Schumer can
put something together that the
president can accept and sell we don't
know either have been fulfilled accept
or sell but the president as we reported
earlier this week is being briefed
almost daily but the systems are gonna
start breaking down and this is not
going to be if it is in any way shape or
form and I'm not suggesting it is a
benign non-threatening shutdown it's
going to get bad soon and the president
has been told sir you're gonna own it if
something bad happens look when the FAA
starts talking about it when the FBI
starts talking about they're saying
warning lights are now flashing yeah he
said he said he wanted to own it he said
he but major can we talk about Roger
stone for sure how do you expect the
President to respond to the news of his
arrest this morning well he can't say
what he's tried to say about Michael
Cohen I don't know him he's not a good
friend and he's only been around for a
short time wrong yeah wrong yeah you
also what he will probably say is well
he was never part of the campaign and I
think one of the ways that the campaign
and the administration will say we never
said people didn't try to do things we
didn't have any knowledge of it we never
gave them authority we never gave them
the option of doing these things what
they might have done on their own is
their business and they're gonna have to
live with the consequences of it but
that is a kind of retrenchment that
suggests they didn't know anything and
we don't know if the evidence will back
them up on it well by the way the the
indictment says stone was an official on
the u.s. presidential campaign they
named him as someone who was working on
the campaign and they also say on page
two stone was contacted by senior Trump
campaign officials to inquire about
future releases from WikiLeaks right so
whether he was officially on the roster
or not
and that's an indictment that has to be
proven that has to be established but
clearly the special counsel believes it
is developed enough to assert those
things in public in ways they have not
been asserted before damaging
all right thanks very much major as
always